Speaker 1: Donald Trump, seemingly extraordinarily
impaired and confused, gave a speech to guests at
Mar a Lago and seems so disconnected from reality
that it's hard to know what is going on in his
brain if. Funny anything. It may be the sort of
situation where, you know, the wheel is spinning,
but the hamsters have long died and flown off
of the wheel. I don't know. Here is Donald Trump
claiming that Joe Biden convinced Vladimir Putin,
the president of Russia, to invade the nation of
Ukraine. What? When did that conversation even
reportedly take place? Listen to Trump and I
apologize. The audio is not exactly perfect.
Speaker 2: Front of everyone's mind. The power
is so destructive that we won't talk about it. I
brought in protesters during the debate. I brought
in protesters. I want to talk about nuclear
catastrophe. And I brought them in from America. I
said, How would you respond when we start talking
about this? They said, Sir, sir, in the best you
can, do not talk about it. It's something you
really can't talk about. It's so destructive.
It's so powerful. The world will be gone. And
now I hear this. And we have a man who has no
mind left. And his mind in prime time wasn't any
good. But he is. And this is the guy negotiating
for us. We have a man that convinced us to go into
boot, because if you look at the psychology that
he used, it's the exact opposite. Putin would have
never, ever gone and he knew the ramifications. Do
you remember when Biden said, well, they might
take some small parts of Ukraine? That was.
That's what Putin wanted to hear. And there'll
be no problem if he takes some parts of Ukraine.
Speaker 1: Delusional, but dangerously so. And
I also I don't really know what goes on at Mar
a Lago. I'm going to be down there in a couple
of weeks. Maybe I'll drive over and see if I
can figure out what the hell is going on at Mar a
Lago. But in all seriousness, I don't even know if
the guests are always expecting to hear this type
of insanity from Trump. Sometimes it seems like
he's just supposed to be congratulating someone
on a wedding or something like that. Not at this
particular event. Donald Trump also attempted
to rewrite history in this very strange speech,
trying to rewrite history about Ashli
Babbitt, the woman who was who was killed
at the January 6th insurrection. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Is what's happening to our country.
Ashley Babbitt's mother was arrested yesterday
because she was protesting the death of her
daughter being shot by a lunatic who's got a
record of not so good. And then they try and
protect him and they just things what they've
done to that family. But they shot her. There
was no reason. And then they arrested because
the mother was in a group and they arrested
yesterday the mother of Ashli Babbitt. So
she loses her daughter. Then on top of it,
she gets arrested and we can let this go on. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, the shot by a lunatic,
Ashley Babbitt did nothing wrong. I want to remind
all of you, Ashli Babbitt was the 35 year old Air
Force veteran who was fatally shot while she was
participating in the insurrection on January six,
2021, in Washington, D.C.. She was part of
a group of Trump supporters who breached the
Capitol building during that attempt at certifying
the 2020 election results. She was shot by Capitol
Police when she was trying to climb through a
broken window. That shooting was investigated.
Now, in every other case, these Republicans say
was investigated. Police did nothing wrong. They
were cleared. We support the police here. They
aren't satisfied with the investigation. Oh,
what a surprise here. They say despite the
investigation, clearing the police officer,
she certainly was doing nothing wrong. The
shooting was investigated. The officer was cleared
of any wrongdoing. I thought they supported the
police. I thought they always agreed with the
exonerations of police officers. No, it's yet
another one of these principles. That's not a
principle. It's a principle. If the outcome is the
outcome they want and if it's not, then it's very,
very bad. We're going to take a very quick
break and be back with more right after this.